il faut répondre qu'ils sont pouvoir
d'achat le président de la république a
été très clair sur l'indexation des
pensions de retraite sur l'inflation sur
l'augmentation du point d'indicé de la
fonction publique sur le triplement de
la prime pouvoir d'achat sur le bouclier
par rapport à l'énergie parce qu'il faut
que les français continuent d'être
protégé par rapport à l'énergie sur le
chèque alimentation parce que c'est
souvent l'alimentation quel est le
produit qui augmentent le plus mais il
ya tellement de bruit et de fureur
depuis l'élection présidentielle entre
show qui conteste le résultat même de
cette élection je pense évidemment à
jean luc mélenchon des solutions toutes
faites ou on parle de de blocage des
prix ce qui serait pire que tout parce
que le blocage des prix ça entraîne des
pénuries ça nourrit encore plus
l'inflation taxe était
pas que vous ne souhaitez pas à voir
avec les oppositions avant les élections
je viens de vous donner le contenu du
texte elle a redit ce que je souhaite
parce que parce que je suis
parlementaire c'est que les
parlementaires à partir du 20 juin
prochain en discute des modalités
concrètement comment on indexe ya par
exemple
des gens delà du ps qu'ils vont nous
expliquer que seul le blocage des prix
vaut alors qu'ils savent parfaitement
que ça n'a jamais fonctionné dans aucun
pays et dans toute l'histoire il faut
plutôt travailler sur les conditions de
mise en oeuvre pour répondre oui des
français aux attentes des français
j'allais lire bruit on entend trop de
bruit et de fureur et le bruit ni la
fureur apporteront des réponses aux
inquiétudes des français l'indexation
des retraites à partir d'une foot
pendant la campagne présidentielle
emmanuel macron 10 et 4 4 et demi pour
cent on est maintenant quasiment à 5%
les économistes les plus pessimistes 10
10% ou est-ce qu'il faut placer le
curseur
exactement au niveau de l'inflation moi
je le dis aussi nettement que ça c'est
la position que le groupe du modem
défendra à l'assemblée nationale que ce
soit d'ailleurs pour les pensions de
retraite ou pour l'indexation de la
fonction publique ça on va rentrer dans
une société dont nos parents nous grands
parents se souviennent ce que j'avais
vécu ça la société de l'inflation est
bien dans ce cas là qu'est ce qu'on
faisait en évaluer pas l'inflation
seulement une fois par an on l'évalué
tous les trois mois où elle évalué tous
les mois et on adapte les pensions de
retraites les salaires de la fonction
publique et aussi les minima sociaux
parce que pour les minima sociaux c'est
peut-être encore plus important parce
qu'on est très petit revenu les des plus
fragiles dans notre société ce que
parfois on ne voit pas donc il faut
savoir aussi en parler pour eux
il faut se scinde excès sur l'inflation
tout simplement elle prévient la
république a été très clair de la
campagne présidentielle il a dit
indexation sur l'inflation et voyez ce
qu'il faut pas déposé parce que si vous
déposez un texte aujourd'hui on est le
26 mai si le 26 mai vous déposez à 4% et
qu'en fait il faut que ce soit 5 5 2 eh
bien il faudra qu'on s'adapte moi je
suis favorable exactement à ce que
l'inflation
soit prise en compte et qu'on adapte la
société à l'inflation ça vaut pour les
clauses de révision de prix dans les
marchés publics ça vaut pour le monde du
btp ça vaudra évidemment dans les
négociations branche par branche pour
les salariés du privé